what's up guys my name is Samuel Leeds I
became financially free starting from
nothing and I filmed it I don't know if
you've seen it however another guy has
imitated the same thing his name is
Dennis he's from Latvia he started with
absolutely nothing and then using the
same principles that I used he started
his journey to financial freedom he's
here at my offices I'm gonna be picking
his brain and see how he's getting on
thanks for coming down man my pleasure
so tell me about how you got started
into property then it's it was crazy
honest but I never thought that I'll be
doing something like property investment
or property intrapreneurship as well
I was a builder before yeah and then I
knew nothing about property investment
all I knew about is like to be a
property investor you must have a lot of
money a lot of cash yeah but once I met
you you know your crash course my mind
completely changed so what you're not
from England no way from from our little
country called Latvia is literally near
Russia if somebody doesn't know yeah so
you moved from Latvia to England went
but it was effort see now I'm 20 free
suggest or would say years ago when we
met I think the first column that was
actually in my office
you made a trip to the office and I
remember thinking this guy is going to
be successful because your energy yeah
you know and at the time in that you
didn't know anything about property you
know you just happen to be in to be in
the office and I'm gonna thinking this
garden to be really successful you had a
great energy and I always say big
energies big bank did you have a big
bank at the time no really seriously no
like many people say they started being
laughing I actually started with - my
wife right
she started nothing in your bank as a
builder came to the crash course what
happened next well I went with my
girlfriend is well and she she was a big
reason why I'm here right now as well
because the other question for a crash
course I was just blown mind as well
like the things that you can do in a
property but it's just incredible
you know and what happened then is I
signed up today
dear people I was really challenging
myself because obviously I know I don't
have that much money
yeah I can't afford this stuff and I'm
standing in front of this table you know
and I an unfilial gosh nah I can't do
this and I just aborted to the run my
girlfriend push my back said you go and
do it I know you can make this I said no
I'm just gonna do it how did you get the
money because it's not a cheap program
it's not cheap but I got friends you
know and and I follow in your as saying
do it a bit later so do it and figure
out like that yeah I to be honest you
know
I always live let like this right now um
I love risks I really love taking risks
before they were like unsecured I mean
like I didn't for if it's a good risk
but now I'm taking risks which I
calculated you know what's the
difference between a calculated risk in
Anam Cara collected risk basically that
difference what I've been doing before
is I know like if I see something and
I'm gonna do it
I don't think about the alcohol I just
go into it yeah when it's calculated I'm
thinking about it outcomes but what what
is the worst-case scenario so I'm not
what to expect and what to do if it's
actually happening okay so you look at
the you look at the best case because
you're naturally optimist
yeah I am but when you're a crazy
optimist you've lots of energy but
little knowledge yeah then you can be
reckless so what you're saying is you
want to be an action taker you want to
be an opportunist but you also need to
be calculated and you to look at the
worst case okay that's interesting so
when when did this happen so when did
you come to the crash course I came to
the US on February 29th February 20 it
must have been yeah so okay which is
only what like six months ago
yeah so tell me what if you've achieved
in the last six months in the last six
months is 360 basically you know I
completely changed
mind said I completely changed my life
you know I quit my job
you know I'm respect by the way
congratulations it was a big step for me
you know put in for some nitro because I
was working in different places but I've
never been staying there for a long time
because it doesn't feel good for me to
work for somebody you know to actually
do work yeah which are I've been told to
do something and I never call this one
motivation is like I feel like something
inside one's like like you know closing
me down and I and I just you know I mean
like I'm just now draining somewhere
because look at age of between it was
like three five and seven
I remember my my nan asked me Dennis
what do you want to be once you're gonna
be you know older and and you know I
said to her I want to be a president
look an age of five you know like most
of the kids think I wanna be like in a
spider-man or Superman or something like
that well at least age I'm already been
like you know finished off eBay and I
don't know what is coming from his life
you know but working at this job like
you know factory jobs warehouses and
stuff you know they step this beast
inside me was closing down that's the
thing yeah and once I said look I'm
gonna quit this job yeah I know what I'm
doing now I'm fake passionate about the
property investment you know and I'm
gonna do this yeah you know and I said
look this is me I definitely won't do
this in a war job you just pulling me
down I don't feel good at it I'm just
gonna do it you know how many how many
people do you think have that desire do
you think that you're rare or do you
think lots of people have that I don't
think that I'm ready you know like I
don't like to speak about myself like
I'm something like special I think
everybody is the same book I think it's
all about reason why no and and and also
what you do what you want to achieve in
the future
you know I'll just say I want to be a
big person I want to be well known yeah
I want to build my legacy yeah I want I
want my family to say like this is
damaged you know people never
to worry about money because at the
moment like in in our family everything
the like I mean my dad mom now they all
hard-working people on these years it's
it's phenomenal I'm so pleased they are
not direct you know but I'm at this
stage now I know I got to pay back ten
times more yeah
do you think that hard work is the key
to success or is it something different
hard work is that easy to to successful
not only hard work what else
definitely a your brain hundred percent
knowledge yeah and dedication as well
and obviously when something is not
happening it's not to be Bob I mean
always try going forward comp going
forward and stuff I mean Marsh large as
I'm coming from kickboxing broad
background for four five years I build
that killing instinct does that make
sense I make sense
I very competitive person yeah I like a
lot of competition you know and this is
something that drives me as well yeah
when I see people look up on me you know
how challenged with you I said yes let's
do it
I don't even think that's a charge let's
do it now and stuff yeah in my life in
property business I always say it's
argot and I'm challenging myself if I if
I can actually achieve it did you have
any doubters when you stepped out to do
property I never had like somebody
turning to my face never had that no I
I'm sure I got something behind my back
yeah but I mean I never had the
situation that that somebody told me to
my face Dennis you can't fail
I mean my family they're always supports
me they say look there is more pushing
harder push harder how you know my mom
my sister it's incredible I'm very lucky
in this aspect yeah because everybody is
supporting me and I'm just like kind of
like attracting people yeah because when
you are a good person you're attracting
could be yeah as well in this six months
my friends have changed as well so I
obviously old friend
now as well because I said look we've
got different mindset I'm not interested
with them anymore as well so when I
joined the Academy I liked all these
people just phenomenal and we just see
the best place I want to be all my life
how did you join the so you have no
money you come on the crash course now
some people would say because when I
started doing training when I met people
like you I'd feel guilty about people
like you when I see people like you I'm
talking about broke people you had
someone that had nothing bricklaying how
much we make it as a bricklayer as a
repair I was making okay so not terrible
deep average average wage but you had
nothing I used to feel guilty about
seeing people like you borrow money to
go on training programs because I think
and I'd feel the weight of the world on
my shoulders because I'm thinking if
they've had to borrow money and then
they're not successful it I'm gonna feel
all fallen up so I used to always advise
people saver wait with you you did the
deal finding extravaganza which set you
back quite a few thousand you borrowed
the money then you're in debt and you're
thinking about the Academy there what
did I say to you you said to me you know
you see my energy yeah for you and every
enemy even though you had no money
you're in the minuses I still was like
do it yeah and the reason is because I
had no doubt that you'd be successful
because I had no doubt because even
though you had no money you know you're
not you're not from you know from the
country you're a bricklayer those those
things don't matter the thing that
matters is your attitude is your energy
and to me I had no doubt so it's it's
great to see have you made the money
back yet in six months and still making
boy I mean yeah right and it's not gonna
be just the pasta keep my property is
going to be as grow like project manager
yes I'm charging for a finder's fee yeah
and it's very percent of the profit that
I'm going to be how much fun display
wi-fi's are quite country and then how
much air you expects to make each month
each month my plan is to make at least
three thousand at the end of this year
okay okay so talk to me about some of
the deals that you've done in because I
know you've done like what rent to rants
about joint ventures you packaged and
sold deals talk to her about some of the
deals I've done quite a few deals
actually and my first deal was for an
investor it was a five major HMO all
unknown suite from in Doncaster
unfortunately that deal fell through
just because somebody else bought a
higher bit on it but it was my mistake
because I didn't chase them up because
what I put my offer they said yes is
accepted you know and there and then
they they went quiet for four days and I
did inform them back like actually
asking what what's going on right after
full days I phoned the back so it's the
deal actually here I said no
unfortunately your offer has been
unsuccessful I said what is the reason
somebody got higher offer who I learned
a big lesson there yeah like since now
if I put any offers
I know that it was good we chase them
always chasing I've always owned a toast
every single day yeah you know so that a
deal fell through well on to the next
one
I got another hitch model as well which
was in Doncaster fire when all organs
sweet this time I was chased about yeah
and I'm secured a deal and it's now in
process to be solved to overseas
investors have you got the money yeah
how much mm well I don't 2,000 pounds so
that's almost your month salary that you
just made just on passing on one day oh
yeah really cool so how do you find how
do you wait when you're doing this and
you find in deals and you passing on to
property investors overseas investors
what's the process how do how do you how
do you go about doing basically their
process is obviously when the investor
is overseas and before I actually
started to look for some deals I'm asked
people
four ferns proof of identity so I know
that he actually ready to go yeah and
for me it's more credibility as well
when I go to an estate agent Allah I'm
working on behalf this person yeah this
is the proof of was that the buyer has
so they take me seriously strong ah so
you find the investors first you get all
their details you find out what they
want then you go to the estate agents or
the oil sellers with this is the person
I'm working on behalf are that do you
take a fee upfront or do you only tell
you how much 500 pounds okay so you
charge a 500 pound or serious yeah is
that refundable it's not okay actually
be signing of an agreement between two
moms I've got to get him up a property
bill if no um there is two options I are
they gonna give them money back yes
or we can extend that sir yes and then
go and every setup like this is always
slightly unique but this you found this
is what works for you so okay so you
take farmers a pound serious fee yeah
you then have two months to deliver the
goods if you haven't delivered the goods
in two months he can either move on or
extend it yeah okay that's genius
yes and how many investors do you have
on you books that have said I'm serious
yeah so we just signed up yesterday
which is serious investor really serious
I'm looking forward to this public is
going to be big and also I got free more
on my books yes and by one investor be
coming through the chest at the moment
I'm not taking more than three investors
outside because I I want to bring a
quality yeah because if I'm gonna take
more investors I'm gonna be focusing on
a lot of areas because every single
investor is unique you know is not their
own vision their own investment area
strategy you know if I'll be taking five
people are we messed up basically now
yeah and there is not because I want to
keep everybody
yeah because if I would take five people
I I could get these four to investors
with them yeah fine it's on that's great
okay so you've got because I think a
good investor is better than a thousand
and sometimes people focus on getting as
many investors as the camel what you
focus on is its quality over quantity
and I tell you something it's all
because when I just started I had 60
investors on my mailing list I put the
axiom I don't I can just kill this no no
sir I found what property do I buy
several guess what not even worried why
Wow you know because I thought those 60
investors they're all looking for lease
options rents around you know but I
don't wanna source this type of this
because partners in the book for for
myself really for the cash flow of
course and and the type of investors I
want is that ready to put money in where
do you live in Peterborough in
Peterborough so that totally makes sense
have you found any of those lease
options rent to rents for yourself rents
around and guess what dude I'm so I'm so
impressed all right tell me about that
how many went immense have you done just
one okay it's through units yeah yeah so
two units to to m1 how much how much is
that making them be still going just
deciding their dream is what it's all
ready now like everything has been
agreed oh yeah and it's a service
accommodation to units yeah in so
they're going to be bringing in at 80%
of occupancy rate 2600
2/3 that's like pretty much your wage I
just read my expenses so yeah and then
obviously I was financially only
educated I was Hispanic on some randoms
don't even need to be honest I was in -
you know but by listening to rap card or
Robert Kiyosaki you yourself as well you
know I said look I got to sort my
financial
right now yes so I was spending around
so far
a month yeah I shrink that down to 1104
so they still yes service accommodation
makes me financially free I will never
have to go back to work
that's incredible and I never will
that's brilliant so just off that one
deal its financial freedom for you on
top of that you're sourcing properties
HMOs and things like that so talk to me
about then the knowledge that you've
learned what what's been the best what's
been the the real aha moments the real
tricks and tips and things that you've
learned on the academy crash course
whatever that have enabled this to
happen obviously Academy is incredible I
recommend to everybody because you guys
provide all the tools all the DOS is not
enough what I learn from you to get me
those two units rented accommodation
took me around 80 phone calls Haiti in
one day you know I mean it's not easy
it's not easy you got to be persistent
yeah
where people like don't get me wrong
like sometimes I had so much negativity
for from the agencies like wow wow okay
obviously that pulling me down will I
said look don't know what do you mean
what do you mean by Joe for now I mean
their agent or any people said then it's
not be doctor ism okay I would you oh my
god but I asked is this possible in the
future maybe excellent I'm gonna put
them in my books that following on yeah
and I got one property portfolio from
one landlord I'm trying to together on a
lease option yeah at the first that he
said no completely no what I said is
there any just maybe like possibilities
in the future I don't know I want to
sell their all these properties okay
that's why I put him in in my books
literally call him one long after I
asked himself how does the cell going
how is her family especially now if you
said
I mean about still selling and I said
work I can help you remember I spoke
about you know last time now he's happy
with two years lease option at the
moment it's not it's not it's not yeah
two years is a bit sure to what you want
yes the power of the follower yeah you
know and for me it's gone for now
if the person would tell me now no
chance I would just okay that's fine
yeah what if I see that there's
possibility in the future yeah so rather
than being disheartened by the no it's
almost a case of celebrating the
activity because when you put the
activity in as long as you've got the
right tools and you're saying the right
thing which you obviously are because
you're on the Academy then you're gonna
get a yes eventually I mean most most
people would probably give up after the
third now you went you had a team Emma
you know I mean like what I learned from
you is obviously energy yeah and then
somebody tells me know what there is
opportunity that motivates me kind of
thing yeah yeah yeah but that that's
most people have to learn that yeah yeah
so what's been talked to me about some
of the joint ventures the friendships
yeah amazing based service accommodation
in suite units and they told some money
in that we're gonna have to put in it's
going to be twelve thousand yeah I'm not
spending even even one penny from house
that workmen an investor this is the guy
that my first investor that I I suppose
him Hakeem up a property for effort so
true you know okay so for instead of
like being okay sorry and stuff i LOL
like i explained in situation was
actually cop coming on and we kept in a
good relationship
yeah okay so i always talking to like
you know messaging is boss or how it's
going things in your life and stuff like
how the investment is well and then one
day i said look i got
opportunity that we can make some money
together say yeah go ahead
no tell me more about it so I I
presented him a deal the area like like
not just by by the pictures and the text
message as well you know it just took a
video and show that all the process all
the numbers relationship I'm so pumped
I wanna go that's it so all the fees the
contracts a furniture the deposit that
you might need to put down for the comes
down to 12,000 yeah he's putting in all
of the money and then what's what's the
profit share them well until he makes
all his money back it's gonna be seventy
percent to the investor and thirty
percent to me yeah once he makes all his
money back it's gonna be 50/50 okay
that's fair that's fair I think the the
power of joint ventures is incredible
what did you think when you first saw me
on youtube or on in my books talking
about buying houses and becoming
financially free start I'm even no money
did you believe it I head obviously I'm
a big believer of anything that you
imagine in your head yeah and I thought
I didn't have that eager until like
under nice no impossible boy I had a
little bit you know what I mean once I
actually started doing it yeah but I
don't know this my money yeah even that
what is good that we start it's still
not my money how did you get the money
for the economy because that is not
cheap it was Facebook s basically i sat
down with Eliot you know yeah Elliot
knows me well yeah like one of our
training advisors yeah yeah amazing
guide you know and then obviously you
said look Dennis people want to see you
in their Academy I said yeah I want to
stop what I don't know how I could make
this money now so I run to one loan
company yeah that I've used before but
they said no to me you know so like ah
that's it well I didn't stop same moment
I
went to my bunking yeah and basically
applied for a loan in five minutes I had
the money my back no seriously
at least I saw those well the money in
your bank in five minutes
Wow do you remember what interest you
paid on that which is really high it is
what I'm gonna make all the money back
towards me about the difference between
good and bad day but then if you get a
debt for a holiday yeah guys you just go
in there and you get nothing basically
you know how good that is when you're
poor but your invest your money into
something into good or product or
knowledge as well which is gonna pay you
back and cover your bed yeah for a for
example if I buy a house on a debt and I
think and I got to pay two hundred
pounds every single month all the
tenants pay me six hundred yeah so
obviously they pay for my death
yeah and plus I got a cash flow hopeful
bunch of parents but without any
management piece yeah is that not risk
is that not really risky though take it
getting debts and stuff I mean what
would people like Robert Kiyosaki and
Grant Cardone and these what would they
advise to do that do you think before I
never wanted to go in there I mean I
said to myself I will never go in there
you know because I was born like this
you know like my parents that never
going that is dangerous is like you know
it's not good so yeah I think so it's
bad but yeah once I started to read to
Robert Kiyosaki Grant Cardone
they they are in debt I mean the country
isn't that yeah how can it be a bad
thing yeah I mean you you just got got
to be really smart you have say you know
I mean if on advocated person takes out
the debt that will be about that bank
and that would be really risky the
interesting thing is the banks they
won't they'll lend happily give you a
loan to go on holiday but to buy a house
they don't want to give you the money
because they say it's too high-risk
why do you think the banks say investing
in property is too risky but investing
on a wedding day or investing on holiday
is no problem
I reckon because obviously if
death or a wedding or holiday they know
that you're gonna come back to us for
more long before if you invest in a
property they know that you're gonna
make money back
yeah so you think that the bank's want
you to fail yeah I think I wouldn't
disagree I wouldn't disagree so why do
you think that investing in yourself is
so important because at the end of the
day knowledge is something that nobody
can set you for me you know even if I
would lose all my money you know I would
be safe okay I'll be there from scratch
because I've done it before I got the
knowledge from you guys you know I got
all these tools you know I know how to
use them yeah and I mean I will never
lose it I never lose it I mean yeah this
is an asset it's going to be forever
where's your serviced accommodation
property Lincoln Lincoln that's a good
area very good area is literally five
steps from the cathedral yeah you know
one is quite a better house and the
second one is cottage okay how do you go
about finding a good area for went to
rent serviced accommodation first of all
I got into the area yeah I see what is
nearby
do I actually like it I also do my
research on their hotels for example if
Premier Inn or Travel Lodge is there I
know it's a good area yes they do it all
that you do which is for you basically
yeah because they're not going to a
hotel varies you know no money okay
there's a friend and then obviously I've
got like a DNA everything and be looking
at my competitors and wondering next
this I'm going to the area and internet
what sells and ask them what is your
occupancy rate I can have been set in a
summer time and stuff I ask you all the
deals I said look I'm just looking in
this area to actually put some
supplementation for professional people
and stuff for for my business uses I'm
not saying that ability Deco competitor
I just said look what you might actually
share some leaders up about the area and
I never helped they always give you the
details because probably you're not
talking to the owner you're talking to
the receptionist who has all the data so
they're not going to be threatened by
you yeah interesting and you learned all
that on the Academy yeah okay that's
great
so talk to me then people watching this
video let's say they're in your
situation a year ago
what's your best advised for them if
they're wanting to get started in
property wanting to become if they've
got that burning desire like you have
and then want to let it out where we
where we wish they star if you've got
that old mythology that death is bad get
out of the dead as soon as possible you
know change that first I would
definitely change that mentality first
because obviously like what I had
experienced was because I got used to
working from nine till five once I quit
my job
obviously you by yourself you're your
own boss now oh man it's like I wake him
up in the morning as like it like feels
like it feels good but I don't feel that
responsibility anymore and then
obviously I changed my mom minds I said
look these are my target this is my
goals this is what I'm gonna achieve
within this month next month like one
year ya know and I got to push it I said
so and my to do tasks every single night
before I go to bed you know for the next
day so once a bake-off look I know I got
to do this and I'm gonna do it step to
that to that to that way yeah you know
and it always keeps me in that motion
mmm isn't do you think there could be a
big risk in someone quitting their job
that they might suddenly become lazy or
unaccountable that there is risk
definitely bought as I mentioned before
there's gonna be some bad times
I mean don't expect that everything's
gonna be coming fast
yeah just one yeah I think before is
well I thought everything's going to be
really quickly for me ya know and I
failed and all week that put me down but
then I changed my mentality I said look
I'm not gonna be expecting everything to
come quickly
yeah instead I'm going to be focusing
all my targets now because you quit your
job and you kind of effectively did the
financial freedom challenge yeah like
like camera I did it do you think me
achieving in a week actually
disheartened some people because they
compare themselves to me or do you think
that it's a good thing because it
inspires them definitely
I mean when I saw your seven-day
challenging chef Phil yeah because it's
possible but then the other thing is
I've got over a decade of experience
I've got all the knowledge so for me I
can do it in a week what's been what's
been the lowest moment for you then
what's been the hardest time in the last
six months I felt lost basically I
really knew like what strategy I should
focus on and which areas well so I felt
kind of oh man I feel like I lost my
track yeah so this is why I invented
this box servicing bra I fought one
investor I know what he's one thing so
you have basically replacing him but the
his skin on to me you know because he's
busy and I got the time this is what I
want to do you know and this is what I
know how to do and that helped him gone
back to the truck you know and be
focused now so they look lowest point as
he said yeah it was basically like you
know worrying about making all the money
but like in time because I quit my job
now so I've got it's a high-pressure
situation you put yourself under you
know you quit your job you had no money
you'd go into a big debt where you pay
19% interest that's a very very high
pressure situation you must have had a
lot of not only self belief but also
belief in in the training and belief in
the system you know a lot of pressure I
don't think many people will be able to
cope and sleep with that kind of
pressure it's a big pressure what I mean
now you've made a success of it yeah you
know I mean you're not you're still only
six months in so you know it's not like
you're a millionaire or anything but
you've got one deal that's going to make
you financially free
you've sold to investors you've got cash
flow coming in you've it's worked but
before that happened you know it's tough
talk to me about you mentioned that you
had to get rid of some old friends talk
to me about that basically obviously my
previous life stuff wasn't the greatest
you know I still was in a keep in keep
boxing
yeah but all the friends they got
different
it's allottee when I quit my kickboxing
career because I just lost the interest
and I achieved what I wanted to achieve
yeah you know I had some bad friends be
like knocked over now like you know how
some traits and stuff and I mean like it
was enjoyable but then I always had
inside me this then expect about this
anymore like you're doing something
wrong like like a little voice inside me
I've been done that was like Grant
Cardone said that beast you know it's
like saying do something come on man you
know get your things back together you
know and then and then like once I
discovered you your company in our
property in the investment I said to
myself look I'm just yeah it's gonna you
know what was on random stuff I mean
what's the difference in the mindset
between your new friends and your old
friends friends you know they want to
enjoy now yeah I mean like they got that
mindset you know live from paycheck to
paycheck my mindset right now is to
focus in the future yeah
create that legacy and then you can
enjoy your life yeah but right now work
your ass off
yeah now to create that song without
really gonna be as well you know other
people I build that cash flow so then
you can enjoy your life yeah you know
wallets away yeah I love that
so what are your plans for the future
then so you get your financially free
now pretty much what's the next six
months gonna like next six months days
I'm gonna be looking to play my people
now as well because obviously I want to
scale you know like by the end of this
year I wanna get some more people
they're gonna be working with me
together like searching for deals
directly wants one big investors because
net for the next two years I'm going to
be focusing on scaling a business I call
a business partner and they and they get
fleeced me you're awesome
we working together he helped me a lot
this is in incredible humans like you
know because and and he said to me
Dennis I see your
I want to help you yeah I was like no
way I mean like it's crazy instead
because you attract all the people yeah
when you change so he helped me a lot by
the beginning of the next year we be
planning planning to get first by reefer
pre finance deal for ourselves well yeah
and then all the money that I'm going to
be made making from those sources are
going to be stacking up then buying
houses brilliant buy three causes reefer
flippin and then buy one house to keep
it again three house to flip it one
house to keep it yeah and initially on a
block of flats dude you're ambitious and
I love it
how long have you known Andy if only I
know where since May okay where did you
meet Andy
on the deal all right I think that's
part of part of the Academy in the
training is he gonna you're gonna meet
people like that and then have an energy
like you've got it is attractive yeah
and you can have a lot of money but if
you haven't got good energy if you
haven't got a good attitude
you're never going to be successful in
any business so I love that I'm really
excited it's been great to get to know
you and thanks so much for coming on the
show we should probably do a part two in
maybe six twelve months dude thank you
so much the reason galaxy is so
successful is not because he started of
a lot of money it's not even because
he's really small it's because he's got
great energy and he's a massive action
taker so my suggestion to you when we
take massive action right now and get
yourself booked on the property
investors crash course there's a link
below and to make it really easy for you
it's free on the house from me no catch
two days advanced property training get
yourself booked on right now take
massive action I'll see you there
[Music]